okay let's get to audience questions
this week this one came in from a few
people but I'm reading it as submitted
by Ricky Ricky says hey David how likely
is it that Trump will not accept the
2020 election results if he doesn't win
this I hate to make this a semantic
thing but it really depends on what you
mean by not accept do you mean will
Trump just say the results were bogus or
do you mean will Trump actually activate
any means he can to try to stay in the
oval office despite the election results
indicating that he has lost the election
because Trump already has not accepted a
whole bunch of stuff that he's wrong
about and it's had no material
importance right what what I mean by
that is Trump didn't accept that
Hurricane Dorian was not threatening
Alabama he used a sharpie to draw a
different weather map but it doesn't
matter that he didn't accept it the
hurricane didn't hit Alabama and actual
meteorologists knew that it wasn't going
to Trump doesn't accept that he didn't
have a record-setting crowd at his
inauguration back in January of 2017 but
it doesn't really matter
Trump doesn't accept that he truly just
genuinely lost the popular vote in 2016
to Hillary Clinton and he even actually
tried to act on that by starting a voter
integrity Commission but the Commission
found nothing and was disbanded and
that's that so let's now go back to the
question is it likely that Donald Trump
is going to say that the 2020 election
was unfair if he loses in 2020 I think
there's an almost 100 percent certainty
of that and there's a few different ways
that he might approach it he might say
it was voter fraud and really he won the
election he might sort of accept the
results but say that it was because he
had the fake news media and who knows
foreign countries whatever working
against him or China or whatever the
case may be now will he actually attempt
to use force to retain the presidency
between November 2020 and January of
2021 when the next president would be
inaugurated I doubt it and if he does
attempt it he will not be allowed to
stay in the end so that is my
a sense of it and I know that there are
a lot of interesting lis this is way
more polarizing for our audience than I
thought it would be even among the left
I mean I know the right is half bought
in on the idea that the only way Trump
could lose is if there is actually some
kind of fraud and I'm not talking to
them but even within the left there are
people who write to me and they say no
David you you're not understanding this
Trump is going to do the things some
people on the right said Obama was going
to do he will declare martial law in
order to justify staying in the Oval
Office or he will try to suspend the
2020 election altogether or whatever I
just don't see you know there was no
chance Barack Obama was going to do that
stuff and I don't see it as something
that Donald Trump is going to do I think
the way that he will fight it is through
a propaganda war and that's honestly one
of the big dangers of the fake news
narrative that Donald Trump has fomented
over the last couple years we've talked
about how the fake news thing has
successfully sort of caught on in the
sense that now any critical report about
Donald Trump is very easy for Trump 'us
to just say it's obviously fake these
are just people trying to take down
Trump it can't possibly be true fake
news fake news that's one negative
element of Donald Trump successfully
running this fake news campaign the
other one though is that you you may be
priming these folks to actually accept
these absolutely outrageous narratives
in 2020 depending on what your election
results are but in the end I don't see
any way that Trump has even a 1% chance
of actually successfully doing any of
those things and quite frankly I think
we need to be focused on winning the
election and getting the vote out and I
know we've got a fight voter
disenfranchisement and voter suppression
and election fraud and foreign
interference I know we've got to do that
but if we get enough people to vote then
it's going to be much more powerful than
anything that they can do and that's
where the focus should be rather than
the idea that Trump's going to suspend
the 2020 election he will say he didn't
lose fair and square but the the margin
of victory should be and could be so big
that in the end it should not really end
up making a difference